Hassan thanks for joining us we're a
pleasure approaching the final what's
your World Cup experience been like
after all these years planning
uh well first I'd like to apologize for
my voice
as you can see it's been it's been a
long uh 27 days
but I have to say uh
it's it's Pride it's happiness it's Joy
it's exceeded expectations
to a large extent you know the first
World Cup in the Arab world the first
World Cup in the Middle East
has lived up
to its name
from great football on the pitch which
we've always promised to a compact World
Cup it's a great Fan Experience fans
being able to watch more than one match
a day and the amount of people that have
just been raving about the fact that
they've been able to watch more than one
match a day and some have actually made
it before matches a day is overwhelming
to what we said as well it's you know
this being a platform from bringing
people together
that's bringing being a platform where
people from different walks of life
different backgrounds able to sit down
and enjoy uh
they're common passion for football
the camaraderie that football brings the
celebration that football brings in and
really you know you can see people from
different cultures just celebrating
together in a way
um that is that has far exceeded my
expectations
it's been such a long journey it's been
a 12-year Journey from the bid to
actually now delivering the tournament
has this world cup achieved what you and
Kata actually hoped it would do
I think
in the meantime yes as of not as a
tournament it has
again let's look back at the promises
that we made
and 20 in in 2009-2010
we talked about a a phenomenal Fan
Experience potentially you want to know
one of its kind never to happen again
where fans can watch more than one match
a day that has happened
we have talked about great football on
the pitch that has happened I mean if
you look at the group stage matches how
many matches have you had up until the
last minute probably the last 20 minutes
I think there's two group stages uh the
one with Mexico and the one with Spain
where within the last 15 minutes you had
who was going to qualify change maybe at
the rate of five minutes
um fantastic football on the ground
Fan Experience like I said just a
gathering of people from different walks
of life
but I think also what's what's very
important to highlight as well is one
thing that I think far exceeded my
expectations again is the fact that you
had Tunisia you had Morocco you had
Saudi playing on home turf and they were
playing on the pitch they were playing
on home turf and that's why they had you
know they had some great results you
know ultimately which is
crowned with Morocco coming forth the
first time in Arab world an African
nation coming forth but I think
this is this was a celebration of the
Arab world
this was a celebration of the Arab
people of our culture of our tradition
of our history people walked in people
might have come in with different
opinions and I've heard I've heard it
from many in particular Europeans saying
that they might have come to support the
team both trepidation a little bit of
concern but they when they engaged with
the Qatari Community when they engaged
with the Arab Community when they engage
with the hospitality sense of welcoming
that we offered them a lot of them
walked away with a different opinion a
different View
and to that extent
it was a platform for bringing people
together
in an unprecedented way one that I'm
extremely proud to be a member of and a
part of
so yes I think it has achieved its goals
what can football learn from this
torment you know you talk about the fans
who've come here is there a sense that
actually
fans feel more welcome in a Muslim
country there are fan groups who didn't
who felt excluded from other events can
football learn from this event in terms
of bringing fans into football I think
it's wider than just football but let me
just break it down slightly
over here now I've had you know my
mother and my mother-in-law for example
following football they never were
football fans you have people walking
from the you know different parts of the
world different you've literally brought
different fan groups coming in families
had a great time there's a lot of
families that I've met that have been
absolutely ecstatic at being able to go
in and celebrate with their families
great football and then be able to leave
so in terms of definitely you know it's
a unique different experience absolutely
but I'd like to take it towards someone
from football learn but I think
generally speak on a wider aspect what
can Society work
what you saw here is people from
different walks of life coming in
trepidation and Arab country and Muslim
country listening or coming in with a
stereotypical opinion of what the Arab
world and the Muslim world has to offer
they've left with a completely different
one a completely positive opinion and
view on who we are you know I was
talking to you earlier the simple the
simplest example was the local dress you
know when I sat down and did a lot of
interviews with a lot of people
especially when I was here I used to get
some people calling me saying if you're
addressing a western audience dress
differently dress more Western because
that way you'll have an audience that
will listen to you a bit more
attentively or at least you'll be able
to deliver your message more efficiently
now I think you just mentioned it Alexi
Lalas and and you know people on Fox
Sports dressed in our clothes you've got
Argentinian fans walking around dressed
in our clothes
um you've got you know we've seen videos
viral videos of young little kids
teaching some people some of the Mexican
fans from the Ecuadorian fans how to
wear the you know that girl you've seen
women wearing it as well
um it might seem like it's a small
cultural exchange but it can have a
profound impact it shows that once you
engage
the fear of the unknown or the fear of
what you assume the assumptions that
build that fear go away and you actually
have an interaction to base your opinion
on and that's what this world cup
provided it provided a platform for
interaction
human to human interaction
people-to-people interaction and in that
it changed the perception of this part
of the world and also it allowed us to
showcase the best in us but also it
allowed us to change our perception of
different fans you know the camaraderie
that you've seen Argentinian fans
the ribbing between each other between
the Saudis and the argentinians and then
the cameroonians and the Brazilians and
so on it was a cultural exchange it was
probably my opinion you know at least
since covet
possibly also even before that one of
the greatest moments of global cultural
exchange between the global South and
the global North
did that lead to need for cultural
understanding we think back to how this
tournament started it was about banning
out cold sales at stadiums was that
ultimately you think necessary to ban
alcohol because it led to a better
environment I think the result today
when you see and again this was a
decision that was taken uh but I think
um you know by FIFA at the time
but when you look at the result today
the amount of people that have come up
to me English fans for that matter
Western fans that have come up to me and
that have said that the atmosphere in
the in the stadiums has been
electrifying
electrifying and some of them are
actually preferred you know no alcohol
in the stadiums now just to be clear
everybody was able to go and find a
drink once they left the stadium before
they came to the stadium everybody was
able to go and get a drink but inside
the stadium you had fans celebrating
non-stop I mean the argentina-mexico
game the Argentina Saudi game
um the Argentina Holland again I'm
saying a lot of Argentina just because
I've been very impressed by the
Argentinian fans but but the atmosphere
has been electrifying overall been
electrifying people have been able to
sit down and enjoy and celebrate
non-stop their passion showing
and at the same time families have been
able to you know sit in a safe
environment having said that going back
to your question
I think
cultural understanding is extremely
important in this day and age
we are
people of different backgrounds who are
people of different communities and
different values
but I think we have to be able to find
ways of expressing our disagreement with
each other
but at the same time being able to walk
away
having disagreed but not conflicted
having disagreed but respecting the
other's opinion and finding ways of
coming together and coexisting together
and there was obviously a lot of focus
on LGBT rights and the legality of
same-sex acts here do you think the
World Cup might have just started to
shift opinions slightly here even if
there's not going to be a law change
that perhaps the World Cup being here
might make people hear more aware of
LGBT people
I think on that matter
everybody's aware
to a large extent
of the issues
on both sides of the argument
the discussions in this part of the
world and again just to work so we're
clear it's not only Qatar this is
something that's within our religious
values this is something that you know a
lot of countries share the same common
values which is more community-based
values as opposed to in the west where
the predominant set of values are
personal rights
um
I think people are aware that we have
differences in opinions but I think it's
important to highlight that we have to
find ways of respecting each other's
opinions and finding a way of moving
forward
and that's what this world cup has shown
again go back to the streets
go back to the streets go back to see
the people go back to see the fans
celebrating go back to seeing the people
from different walks of life and
different backgrounds celebrating
getting together
setting side their differences I mean
again one thing to highlight when
Argentina lost to Saudi the Saudi fans
came out they were singing right and
it's a very famous song where is Messi
where's Messi they were singing about
that they were sitting down ribbing and
making fun of the Argentinian fans but
in good spirits and the argentine's last
ticket
that in itself and then when Saudi lost
and went out you know there were Clips
where Argentina fans were willing and
looking for Saudis I think there was a
clip of uh one of the matches I think
was Argentina Holland where an
Argentinian fan had a had a plaque
saying where's Saudi
it showed that we can we can sit down we
can be different we can you know we can
make fun of each other and so on but we
can do it in a way in the spirit where
it can still move forward together and
today and in this divisive world
it's it's more important than ever to
find these platforms that recognize that
we can move forward together even though
we might not share the same opinions on
certain things there has been suffering
with this world cup migrant workers have
died how many migrant workers have died
in building up the infrastructure
in Qatar for this world cup
I want to clarify something
so the organization that I'm responsible
for the Supreme committee from day one
they've captured all data relating to
incidents unfortunately deaths
whether it's work related or non-work
related and we took the initiative in
ourselves to ensure that we capture both
work related and non-work related deaths
to try to
learn from these so that these
strategies did not occur
on World Cup projects which means
stadiums and within host country
operations we've had three work-related
deaths that we've investigated looked
into and learned from
and unfortunately we've just recently
announced two work-related deaths that
have occurred during the tournament
in terms of non-work related deaths it's
37 non-work related deaths now the
number that
people had caught up on or had brought
up which I mentioned which was 414
deaths that had occurred from 2014 to
2020 this is in relation to all
infrastructure projects all work related
deaths relating to all over the
country's overall development projects
and construction work whether it's major
construction or otherwise that is the
number that is out there it's just to be
very very clear
414 deaths but 414 too many people would
say one death is too many Rob one death
is too many there is no doubts about
that
and we are definitely
um
we definitely try you know try our best
to ensure that such tragedies do not
occur
and again our condolences goes to all
the family members
but it is important also for us to be
able to uh
be transparent
capture this information
so that one we can look towards the
families
and two to learn from these problems
from these mistakes learned from these
issues and ensure that it doesn't happen
again and do the best that we can to
ensure that doesn't happen again
the Arab world is any more united after
this world cup have you met a lot of
hours while you were here have you
spoken to a lot of Arabs you tell me
obviously through football they can be
United but I think the region actually
has longer lasting effects I think as a
result of the World Cup actually some of
the divisions will actually be healed
look as the Arab world as the people of
the Arab world we're one
we share the common history we share
common cultural traditions and beliefs
and values
football has a unifying power like no
other
so there's no doubts that it's the you
know this world cup the first World Cup
in the arrow board in the Middle East
for us is a proud moment because we've
said from day one
you know His Highness has said it this
is an Arab World Cup
and I believe every Arab throughout the
Arab world has a sense of Pride and
ownership in this because it is their
World Cup it is our World Cup
and I do think that Catalyst that
accelerate that sense of Pride that
everybody feels walking around
it's up to us to harness it going
forward
and I believe we will
what is the future for Qatar what will
people see in a post-world cup cat on
what do you hope Qatar achieves on the
world stage
I think it's important to highlight what
we've achieved already
you know Qatar existed before the World
Cup Qatar will continue existing after
the World Cup I mean to the extent that
you know Qatar is a player in the global
Community it is a you know we recognize
our role within the global community and
our responsibilities toward the global
community
I'll highlight two simple examples where
people might not be aware of in
Afghanistan when um but when Taliban
took over there were a lot of people
that were stranded in in Afghanistan and
there was a lot of airlifting happening
it was as a result of the cooperation
the collaboration the support that Qatar
provided to the international
governments that we were able to host
people here were able to evacuate a lot
of people a lot of journalists I believe
you've spoken to a lot of them a lot of
news uh
Outlets whether it's written or or
media broadcast or so on we were able to
support them and get them out of
Afghanistan that role a lot of people
are not aware of our role for example
during covet and repatriating a lot of
people when everything shut down in the
world and there were a lot of people
that were left stranded throughout the
world it was the Qatar the government
that took a step
supporting governments of the world and
repatriating people from different parts
of the world back home this is the world
of Qatar play because it recognizes its
responsibility and its duties towards
the global community
and will continue doing that
what the World Cup offers
is
we've showcased our ability we've
showcased our ability to host a major
event but at the same time we've
upgraded as a result of it our
infrastructure which always was done for
the purpose of our future plans and our
overall development goals which is
represented in our cultural National
Vision 2030. does this make Qatar more
influential more powerful and better
protected now on the world stage being a
small country where those threats had
always existed I don't know these are
these are for you know political
questions that I wouldn't be able to
answer what I can say is this
we're proud of what we've been able to
achieve
we're proud of you know of the fact that
we were able to bring people together
we showcase the Arab world and we
showcase what you know the best of what
the Arab world has to offer our
hospitality
our sense of welcoming
our culture
um you know you can see it and when
people left the thumbama stadium and
people of the neighborhood coming out
and offering Refreshments to the fans
walking out
we're able to Showcase also the global
South and the ability and the simple
fact that the global South
uh can achieve what people might
consider to be impossible they brought
you know for us it's a simple fact
today the Arab world and Qatar
Stands Tall and proud and being able to
Showcase to the world
a unique way of hosting a World Cup
and the unique impact if you harness the
power of the World Cup in the right way
what it can achieve and again I take you
back to the streets I take you back to
the people I take you back to the fans
Not only the Argentinian fans but the
Senegalese fans
the Ghanaian funds the cameroonian fans
were able to get access to this world
cup were able to come and celebrate in
the stadiums to the extent that their
national teams felt like they were on
home ground when Morocco or Luis Enrique
himself said when they were taking the
penalties they felt the pressure his
players felt the pressure
because they were actually playing in
Morocco's home turf so should an
Olympics be next we'll catch up bid for
Olympics now
uh I you know I know that we've got
Ambitions to bid for the Olympics we've
done it a couple of times before so I
know there might be an Ambitions towards
it but it's not within me that's within
the Qatar Olympic Committee so when you
meet them post a question to them my
friend as we look ahead to tomorrow's
final obviously no cats are in the final
but is this the dream final four Qatar
given the fact that two of the stars of
Paris Saint-Germain killing a buffet
Lionel Messi are in this final
I mean look it's a dream final for a lot
of people absolutely you know you've got
the rising star Killian mbappe you've
got what is you know who in my opinion
if he wins it would be a very very
strong candidate to be the goat to be
the greatest of all time
um
it's it's definitely a showdown between
two teammates and at the same time
you know two rivalries very powerful
rivalries
France has played electrifying football
phenomenal solid football let's say
solid football
Argentina has played great football but
with you know individualistic
um masterpieces and genius moments from
Messi
I think every every fan of the game
today is going to be glued in to watch
the match
but then again the football throughout
this entire tournament has been great
and again it's reflected by the way on a
number of different things but one of
the things that's reflected on is in the
broadcasting numbers
if you look in the U.S record
broadcasting numbers in the major
markets if you look at France and I've
seen the numbers I think for Brazil
you know numbers are definitely far
exceed Russia
um so I think the winner generally
speaking of this tournament are the fans
where the fans that have come and
experienced the first Arab World Cup in
the Middle East on the ground and in the
stadiums or it's the fans that are
watching great electrifying football
through their screens but either next
Soul surprise because it is two stars of
one of qatar's big sporting Investments
who are getting to sort of Shine On the
World Cup finals look this is you have
to look at it purely from this is the
World Cup
this is biggest and bigger than anything
else this is the biggest sporting event
in the world Barnum nothing comes close
to it and more importantly
what makes this tournament even greater
is that what you had was a Congregation
of people from different teams together
celebrating together
now you know most other tournaments
people are in different cities
celebrating it differently and so as you
go towards the stadium you feel the
World Cup as you go farther further from
the stadium let's say the the the Allure
of the world cup or the magic of the
World Cup kind of Fades here it's been
there for 27 days a carnival and a
festival that lasted for 27 days with
people from different walks of life
celebrating that is
that is the success of this tournament
or one of the major factors of the
success of this tournament so whoever
wins tomorrow
it'll be a beautiful story whoever wins
tomorrow will be a great conclusion to
what's considered to be a great
tournament inside and outside the
stadium for all the joy do you think
you'll still be forever
trying to prove this case to the critics
the fact is even in Europe throughout
this tournament there was one headline
of British paper Every Good Feeling
Qatar is lined with guilt
how to respond to those people we've
always said it we don't need to respond
to these people
we've utilized this tournament as a
catalyst for positive change and we've
been able to achieve it
the achievements that this tournament
has has or this this world cup has been
able to achieve
on the pitch and off the pitch
are
mentioned and brought up
by International organizations not by
ourselves
we respond on the ground by results I
will move forward for ourselves
in line with our values and line with
our beliefs
This World Cup itself and the
achievement of this World Cup has
responded to everybody
we are proud of what we're able to
achieve
and more importantly
the success will not end
or the progress will not end
tomorrow when the final whistle was
blown it will continue
obviously if you reach the end point
still people will obviously say Qatar
should never be in awarded the
tournament it's all still corruption
associated with the tournament let's be
very clear on as things get brought up
we have to be very specific and what
gets brought up because I think a lot of
people run with one or two words and
then they draw this whole picture around
it and that is the problem in this day
and age I think you know it's it's
taking a word and then building this
scenario around it we have to be very
clear we have to be very specific as
well on things so if you have something
be specific about it but what I will say
is this
have you spoken to African journalists
have you spoken to Arabic journalists
have you spoken to Asian journalists
have you seen the coverage that's coming
out of Africa
have you seen the coverages coming out
of the Arab world have you seen the
coverage that's coming out of Asia even
South America have you seen the
coverages coming out of there
it's a celebration
it's a celebration and more importantly
it's a recognition of a promise that we
made 13 years ago that is actually being
achieved on the ground today
that everybody's been able to experience
that
I don't like saying it but I dare dare I
say it I think the global South to a
large extent has been able to embrace
this
tournament as theirs
now unfortunately if we talk about the
criticism there's a lot of criticism
that has come out from other places that
is
in certain extents I have to say you
know
very disappointing
I think German newspaper picturing
Moroccans stealing the World Cup trophy
from Gianni uh Dressed in track suits as
if they were thugs
just recently I'm not mistaken I think
there was a Danish TV channel I can't
remember the details of it but and
what's considered one of the most
probably emotional moments
that we've been able to see see where
Moroccan players were embracing their
mothers
for what has been a historic achievement
not only for Morocco but for the Arab
world as well for 450 million people
and members of a Danish TV
compared that through a photo to monkeys
Gathering Together
so with all this respect
we move on
we deliver on the ground
we deliver results
we made a promise in 2010 2009 and we've
delivered throughout the tournament and
the tournament itself has delivered on
these promises as well that we've caught
on ourselves
and it's been embraced by the Arab world
it's been embraced by African nations
it's been embraced by the Asian world
it's been embraced by a lot of people
and it's a celebration and that for us
is the perfect response to anybody it's
quite a lot of frustration of how Europe
reacted to this world cup the fact yeah
the entire Germany team with their sort
of Silent gestures on the pitch
I think if there is frustration it's
been it's been countered by celebration
like I said by the fact that every
person you talk to from different parts
of the world has celebrated this
tournament and considered it theirs
by the fact that you talk you know I've
even seen German fans I've seen you know
I think there was a clip of a German fan
came and said that they were concerned
about coming here but they were actually
ecstatic and they were blown away by the
welcoming nature of Qatar of the Qatari
people of the people living in Qatar and
the Arab world
so as much as they might have been
frustration but there was also Joy
to the fact that when you speak to fans
on the ground and that's why I urge you
and I urge everybody here as well who
sees us to speak to fans if anybody
knows of somebody that's come and
experienced the World Cup and Qatar to
go speak to them
if everybody if anybody knows him even
if it's a 60 degree of separation
situation and before forming your mind
before making a call if you have not
been here please talk to people who've
been here
talk to people who've actually
experienced it
talk to the fans that know in four years
time the likelihood of them being able
to follow their teams is diminished
extensively
talk to the Indian fans who never
thought in their lives they would ever
be able to watch the tournament and yet
they're here
there's a clip I saw of an Indian fan
who supports Brazil who is fanatic about
Brazil absolutely fanatical about Brazil
and somebody had taken a
a video of him you know talking about
how he loves Brazil and you can see he
was very emotional never in his life did
he ever think that he was going to be
watching Brazil on the field
these moments
washing all the frustration during the
tournament the European groups have been
part of the way for working group the
European nations put a statement out I
think they said they would welcome the
direction things like compensation and
how that was moving on on migrant
workers
what will the Legacy be do you think for
the migrant worker population are there
guarantees of the funding to actually
compensate those who have suffered those
who've lost those family members who did
die other assurance and cats are going
forward the fact that those families who
have lost people building this world cup
building the country will get the
compensation
again I think it's important first uh
you know to point out that every person
that's contributed to the development of
this country is a valued member of of
Qatari Society every person
we've endeavored and like we've said
this tournament for this tournament to
be an accelerant
to improve the conditions for uh on
labor reforms because the situation
previously was not acceptable
despite the best of intentions the
situation was not acceptable and the
World Cup has accelerated a lot of these
reforms or contributed to accelerating
these reforms the country's made
initiatives and we've actually within
our standards have created initiatives
I'm very proud to say today in terms of
workers in terms of worker
inspections on host country operations
I just like to highlight this so what
we've done is within the tournament we
work a welfare unit within the Supreme
committee it started has done
inspections on host country operations
which could include Hospitality included
security include a supply chains
catering and so on it was an extensive
exercise
we've I think performed
for a Workforce of about 68 000 have
performed about eight thousand to nine
thousand uh
uh interviews we've identified a lot of
issues we've been able to identify
issues early on through our tendering
process or our vetting of the tendering
process some companies have been able to
go through uh despite our best
intentions and we've been able to find
them and address them to the extent that
about 90 percent of the issues that
we've identified have been able to be
rectified and 10 percent will be
rectified if not by the end of the
tournament and very soon beyond that
just to highlight how serious we've
taken our commitment also during the
tournament on the operational side as
well not purely on the construction side
which was previously
and of course as we said I mean I think
the minister has come out and made a
statement that yes there is a fund the
workers support an insurance fund that
will be looking to any matters relating
to unfortunate deaths
and that will and that will continue
beyond the World Cup that is a
commitment that the government has made
that the ministry has made that extends
beyond the World Cup onwards I mean
that's the compassion perhaps that some
people might have assumed watching it
comments profile doesn't exist but you
clearly Qatar feels the pain of anything
Rob let me be very clear about this
before we hosted the World Cup before we
bid for the World Cup
the country recognized the need for
reforms
because the condition was unacceptable
and the laws were put in place there was
issues of enforcement
and there were issues of legislation
that needed to be needed to change
because at the time I thought it was
sufficient it was good enough it needed
to change in all cases
now the World Cup we utilized the World
Cup as a catalyst to accelerate these
reforms it was not done as a result of
criticism it was not done to address
criticism it was done in line with our
own values our own beliefs and that is
why we utilize and harness the power of
the World Cup to achieve this
and we've said it before this is not the
first time that I say it
some changes might have come at a slower
Pace but we tried to do it in a way to
ensure at our own pace within their own
our own circumstances to ensure that
these changes
are sustainable and long-term changes
that lasted beyond the tournament
we value everybody that lives on public
and so
rest assured
the legacy of this tournament was
delivered before the tournament and will
continue delivering beyond the
tournament and again not to satisfy the
critics
but it is out of our own values to be in
line with our own values
which you think other countries can
learn from Qatar in the region yes I
think we have Germany in 2024 I think
there's a lot that Germany can learn
from us in the Euros there's no doubts
and we've been talking to
the organizers in 2026
but keeping in mind the 2026 I think is
you know is a slightly different Dynamic
three different countries each country's
vast spaces so obviously the Dynamics of
the countries are different but we
definitely had I've had some discussions
with a number of uh
or government officials of host cities
that have wanted to
understand our experiences as well but I
believe absolutely but when it comes to
for example you know and I've had the
discussion with a number of German
officials as well I do believe that
there's a lot that they can learn
especially when it comes to auditing the
supply chain in Germany and the workers
issues in Germany as a result of what
the Supreme committee has been able to
achieve so yes I think there's a lot
that other countries can learn from us
I'm from North America and by the way
just so we're clear I'm not saying it
out of hubris I'm not saying it out of
vanity I'm saying it out of you know the
simple concept of progression
we've been able to host a successful
tournament we have set up standards
worker welfare standards that has been
commended by even human rights watching
amnest International themselves and so
it only makes sense in major sporting
events look towards us to learn from us
it is the simple natural way of building
on the successes of the past and
learning of the mistakes of the past as
well
obviously the 2026 World Cup is spread
out across three on three countries
people have raised all sorts of
environments questions about that it's
been a compact World Cup means that
hasn't been the travel but people
obviously look at this world cup and say
so which has been built is it
environmentally friendly why do they ask
that question in the sense like what's
what's you know there's a lot of other
countries that have built as well if we
look at the infrastructure that was
built this is infrastructure that is
needed for the country's overall
development
so if you look at the Metro System the
Metro System was not built for the World
Cup
the Metro System was built for the
country's overall development plans the
expressways the upgrading of our
telecommunication systems all of these
were in line with our overall Urban
Development plans and goals the World
Cup accelerated certain initiatives
prioritized certain initiatives yes or
certain projects but in the end every
penny that was spent out of the 200 plus
billion dollars that people speak about
was not for the World Cup and it's very
important to highlight that this number
was upgrading the infrastructure that
this country had planned for for its own
for our own purposes of overall
development and it's a very important
distinction to be made so it's
development you know it's our legitimate
ambition to be able to create world you
know state-of-the-art and world-class
infrastructure which I'm very proud to
say that we have today
which will feed and support our overall
future Ambitions as a nation
in terms of the stadiums the stadiums
have been built in a sustainable manner
we have developed construction standards
that have allowed us to build the
stadiums in a sustainable manner
sourcing our materials in a responsible
sustainable manner one of our stadiums
which was Stadium there was a stadium
previously there it was completely
demolished ninety percent of that
material was recycled into the stadium
974 Stadium designed in a way where it's
built and a completely disassembled
the fact that you don't have to travel
from different parts you know on plane
and so on and public transportation was
available reduced what is considered to
be the biggest footprint for many
different tournaments which is
transportation footprint the carbon
footprint of a transportation footprint
was able to be reduced dramatically in
relation to that and the other
initiatives that we've undertaken for
example in terms of sustainability if
I'm not mistaken I believe we've been
able to recycle about 70 percent of the
material of the waste and I think the
rest is being used for waste of energy
to the extent that we're trying to
minimize if not completely eradicate any
waste going to landfill now this is
going to be the first tournament of its
kind to ever be able to achieve that
so when we talked about sustainability
we've undertaken initiatives that I
don't think any tournament previously
or even again you never know nobody ever
knows about the future but as of yet no
tournament has made that commitment or
event has made that commitment and it
and delivered on the commitment as we
have done that the country has built an
800 megawatt solar farm
as part of our commitment towards
cleaner energy
that contributes and offsets a
significant portion of our carbon
emissions within the network within the
overall network of the country
so our commitment even to renewable
energy and renewable technology is seen
on the ground and achieved it's not a
promise that we will do it we promise
that we will do it and it has been
achieved in terms of sustainability so I
tell you you know I say this
our commitment
to a sustainable tournament there's many
examples and the numbers themselves will
show you and the initiatives themselves
will show you that we have also achieved
or at least are in the process of
achieving a lot of the commitments that
we've made on the sustainability front
as well it's part of it just making it
part of the conversation at least so
it's actually just recognized well it's
not no it's not just part of the making
a part of the conversation I don't
believe that I think you should be able
to achieve things on the ground there
should be you should Showcase of show a
road map that people can follow and
build upon and hopefully achieve even
greater things that is what these
tournaments are meant to be because
being part of a conversation I think a
lot of these tournaments have have
created moments of conversation
over over decades and generations but
they become part of a conversation and
the conversation dies down
when you have initiatives on the ground
and they're tangible initiatives and you
showcase even if it's a small initiative
but if you can show a roadmap probably
able to achieve it you can build on that
it is a tangible Foundation that you can
build upon on the labor reforms we
showcased how we're able to sit down and
utilize and harness the power of this
tournament to be able to achieve labor
reforms and again we can differentiate
we can we can disagree on the extent of
the labor reforms that have been
achieved whether acceptable or not but
the reality is that you cannot deny is
that progress has been made progress
recognized by International
organizations has been made on the
ground this is a showcase this is an
example of how major other tournaments
can utilize the power of these
tournaments in that regards
sustainability the initiative that I
just I uh highlighted and outlined are
an example of how these tournaments can
be utilized
to Showcase initiatives that touch
people's behaviors that touch people's
hearts that people can follow and become
road maps and blueprints that future
tournaments can build upon so it doesn't
have to be a tournament that is
successful and we put in a box that say
thank you very much and the next
tournament starts from Ground Zero
each tournament can build upon the other
as we go along and this is what this has
to we'll have to offer I just feel
things to close up man just for just one
of the big issues in this tournament
because it was early on
the fans have had rainbow hats rainbow
t-shirts taken off them or they were
stopped was that frustrating because
you'd always had the message that
rainbow items would be allowed and it
was just a question of the message not
getting through right to the you know
Security on the stadium and is there
some regret on the toilet that the fans
went through it when actually you wanted
look I think I think you know some fans
were able to go in without without
issues and some fans unfortunately did
you know did face issues
um I think overall
and obviously as you know as we've
always said you know that situation I
think some of the security people might
have taken a decision at the time to see
what was best whether you know in fear
of intentions Rising inside the stadium
or not but regardless of that I think
you know one one point that we tried to
highlight and we've had you know we'll
be getting reports in the end you know
one of the most important achievements
that we've been able to achieve in this
tournament and that I hope it becomes a
benchmark for other tournaments as well
is we've been able to implement I'm not
mistake I think it's the first one of
its kind human rights volunteers
we've been able to have you know we've
actually had human rights volunteers out
on the on you know their role was simple
to go observe incidents whatever
incidents it may be not to interfere but
to highlight it write it down call in
and call in the incidents that they
speak and that I think you know is
showcases our commitment towards
ensuring that people's rights are not
violated and to the extent that you know
unfortunately some some incidents might
occur
um
it's not just here we've seen a sentence
that have happened for example in
England we've seen incidents that have
happened in France in the Champions
League final that was that was one of
the examples that comes to mind we've
seen a lot of incidents that happen
overall but we try to you know try to
approach it in a manner of transparency
so we have these people that go in try
to capture these moments capture these
incidents inform us some of these
incidents are one-off if they're issues
that are Beyond being one-off incident
we try to fix it as well and so you know
which led to again if you speak to a lot
of the fans
I don't think I've met any fan
and maybe that's the case of every
tournament right
they say this but I don't think I've met
any fan as of today that has not said
that this is the best Tournament of
their lives
that they've ever gone to I've met fans
that have gone through World Cups since
1998.
and they've said that this is the best
world cup that they ever attended I've
even met an Argentinian fan that said
that he's never experienced an
atmosphere
and energy as he did in the Morocco
Spain match and that's because he's
never attended matches of Morocco he's
never attended matches in Egypt or Saudi
it's exposed the world to a culture that
they never would have been exposed to
before in their lives
and that's
that's what this tournament has left
on the flip side you've got set letter
and other fans in Europe saying this
Trump should never even been to Qatar
I can't answer that all I can say is
this is the first World Cup in the Arab
world in the Middle East
this is It's been embraced by the Arab
world and more importantly also or more
inclusively it's been embraced by the
global self
we've been able to showcase our our
hospitality and our Rich culture
which in history and tradition
and the fact is every fan that's come in
from any part of the world has loved it
English fans have loved it German fans
have loved it Dutch fans have loved it
Argentinian fans have loved it
Senegalese fans have loved it
cameroonian fans have loved it Indian
fans have loved it Bangladeshi fans have
loved it
Saudi fans have loved it Moroccan fans
have loved it Tunisian fans have loved
it
and what I'm saying and I'm talking
about these fans by the Numbers I'm not
talking about a group of 100 or 200
people who have been able to secure
their visas I'm talking about fans that
at least are 500 strong or a thousand
strong who've been able to come and
support their teams
they've loved it
so to the extent that anybody says that
I would say
they haven't experienced it on the
ground
they have not experienced it on the
ground and I've heard from many people
that as a matter of fact I won't talk
about I won't say the individual but
some person a person was sitting down
doing an interview with a number of TV
agencies and one of the family members
was living somewhere in Europe called
him up and said you know you're doing
all these things and you're saying all
these great things but
you know I'm seeing all this different
stuff on TV
and he said don't watch the you know
these channels watch the ones that are
in Argentina watch the ones that are in
uh what's it called Brazil and so on
watch this coverage
and it was a completely different
coverage as you prepare for the final is
they relief that this world cup has
finally been completed there were so
many threats at Point she had the
boycott and blockade in the region you
had the investigations over the years he
had such a long build up is the relief
actually you managed to Stage the World
Cup and complete it you've known me for
how long now Rob
throughout the bed and you've known all
the members of the good for how long
more or less throughout the bid
have you ever had the feeling that we've
been anything less than confident
we've been confident that the tournament
was going to be held we've been
confident about the results
and now we're proud
we're proud of what we've been able to
achieve
we're happy
and a sense of pride
is a collective Pride
of the Arab people
it's a collective Pride of the Arab
people
and then
so tomorrow when the whistle blows for
the final
it'll be 450 million people in the Arab
world celebrating
their tournament
thanks a lot thank you very much thank
you it's been nice thank you a long
journey